[Applause]
thank you guys
thank you oh my goodness who where was
that
queen at live aid sinatra at madison
square garden the sex pistols of the
chalet du lac
in paris judy garland at the london
palladium no it was
tucker carlson receiving a rock star's
reception
at the talking point usa summit earlier
this month
here are some of the highlights from his
spectacular speech
the first thing you need to know is
what's actually happening
this is not you know your enemy
as horrible as they are is not some
crazed ideologue wearing black spray
painting
statues that person is loathsome and
should be in jail trust me
and i call for that nightly but your
actual enemy is the person who's funding
him
and making that kind of behavior
possible and is doing it for a very
specific reason
to tear down the past
to destroy the past now why do they want
to destroy the past
because when you destroy the past you
eliminate all reference points
if you have no idea what came before you
you have no idea what normal is
and you cannot understand the
consequences of what's happening now if
you can't look to the past and
understand the consequences of the same
behavior in another time
right the root of wisdom is knowing
what happened before i mean that's the
road map
so when you destroy that you have an
entire country
that is very easily manipulated okay so
the first thing to know is that's what's
going on
the second thing to know is that
small is almost always better than big
that's the truth the circle of people in
your life
who care enough about you to help you
when things go wrong
is really small a lot of people
you're friends with on instagram or
facebook or whatever in the fake digital
world that we've been lulled into
participating in
but the actual number of people who will
take affirmative steps to help you
is very very small it's not 350 million
that's how many people are in this
country it's not seven billion
it's like eight so your loyalty
always has to be to them to your family
and your closest friends above
anything else period
and anyone who tells you otherwise
anyone who tells you that your real
loyalty has got to be to some larger
group of people some political group or
some group of people who look like you
give them the middle finger those are
your enemies i'm serious
i'm serious they are trying to destroy
the fortifications that will protect you
through life
which are the people you love and who
love you back
tucker on cracking form there and making
a big
point uh that a society that has no past
has no future it's as simple as that